britney spears impassioned court
appearance grabbed the world's attention
and the pop star hopes her words can be
a catalyst for change
on wednesday brittany expressed many of
her frustrations to the los
angeles court in the pursuit of ending
her years-long conservatorship and e.t
has new details
about britney's motivation leading up to
the court appearance
while britney's statements drew plenty
of focus to her own case
it might also bring awareness to others
who are facing similar circumstances
a source tells e.t she hopes her words
will help set some sort of precedent
and maybe one day make a difference for
capable adults to take over their own
finances
she is tired of listening to everyone on
her team about how she should live her
life
or spend her money brittany's
conservatorship is said to have left her
with little control over her money and
assets
the source goes on to say she feels
manipulated by opportunistic people
not just her father but people who
financially control her estate
and feels there are many people who have
taken part in manipulating her situation
for their own personal gain et has also
learned that jaime's personal financial
decisions
could be called into question the source
adds she feels her father is more
interested in her
finances than being her dad she feels
like her father
is not qualified to make decisions about
her finances
because he doesn't know how to handle
his own finances
there was no shortage of shocking
accusations in brittany's court
appearance
among them britney's claims that under
her conservatorship
she's not allowed to get married or have
a baby
telling the court this conservatorship
is doing me way more harm
than good brittany added i want to sue
my family to be totally honest with you
britney's father jamie was named
conservator over her person and estate
in 2008
and brittany and her court-appointed
attorney have filed paperwork to have
him removed
i don't understand how he can be such an
ass and be so nice
in the 2008 mtv documentary brittany for
the record
we saw plenty of these tense moments
between brittany and jamie
the best thing for her is what she's
doing right now let's give her
that she's in her element she's in her
world and uh
and keeping her busy this is my dad
brittany get your ass in here
brittany get your ass in here you met
phone i hold that damn phone for you
no daddy
now all eyes are on britney's father to
see how he'll respond
the judge will probably hear from jamie
and hear his
position on this whether he wants to
remain basically his choices are remain
and try to fight
and remain as her conservator or say you
know what
i'm not even gonna fight i agree with
brittany if she doesn't want me
fine but i do think she needs someone
else or thirdly
he might agree potentially and say that
she should not even have a
conservatorship at all
you